[Music]
[Applause]
my team is crazy
a show-stopping performance on The Voice
has Blake Shelton calling out fellow
judge Chance the Rapper I mean come on
this is cheating I love beating the
other coaches it's it's what they pay me
to do team chances group sister Trio
Sorella closed the playoff rounds with
the rendition of Christina Aguilera's
Something's Got a Hold on Me from the
2010 film Burlesque
happened to me
[Music]
this way
the song wow chances fellow coaches
Niall Horan and Kelly Clarkson the
energy off you guys is insane I think
you'll be missing a beat if you didn't
have these with you in the semi-finals
for sure
so fresh it's just like unlike anyone
else I think that makes you stand out
thank you so much it's been awesome
Kelly's very very sweet very nice to me
um Blake is here and
yeah but Blake thought it was too good
to be true I mean come on this is
cheating
two perfect but he's still impressed by
the performance I loved the individual
moments that you guys had it was like oh
you think we all three can't do this
separately too like watch this you know
I mean you're going to put them through
aren't you are you putting those through
well we'll talk about it well in the end
chance does put the trio through as one
of his two artists to move on to the
live semi-finals Sorella was amazing
smashed one of my favorite things about
working on the show because I love
playing with harmonics they really went
for it on this one that was crazy yeah
their performance was phenomenal today
if team null don't win
Sorella deserve it as for Blake his
final go around as coach is almost over
in case you didn't know that the country
star could earn his 10th win but seems
like he's going to have tough
competition going into the finals what
is the strategy to try to keep him from
winning number 10 and you one of you
taking it home and all your followers
you've got a ton of followers yeah use
the followers use the social media have
people online well I'm just like doing
the same thing but I mean social media
use your social media power yeah I'm
very if he wins I am very happy for him
because that is super cool to win on the
last season and he's literally the show
and from its conception but like I'm not
like rooting for him to win I'll be
happy for him if he does but I'm
obviously trying to win myself for like
my team
[Music]